All right,
we're going to play a video real quick and then a liquid and I are going to talk
about it.
Sounds good.
Let me find it.
I'm already failing here.
Alright,
well you know when you also have to look with regards to that.
The shadow ideas like you have to get in touch with your anger.
You know,
lots of people are resentful about all sorts of things.
They're resentful about,
oh
women and they're resentful about men and they're resentful about the patriarchy
and they're resentful about the left wing,
resentful about the right wing and the resentful about politicians and they're
resentful about the cataclysmic force of nature and its ability to make people
sick and and suffer and they're resentful about their own inadequacies in the
boat.
Their bad parenting and God like the list is just bloody endless and that can
make you very,
very angry and that's part of that resentment and cynical and bitter and dark
and full of fantasies about destruction and the desire to bring things down and
the wish that everyone else suffered and the desire to shake your fist at God.
And all of that's really dark.
You know,
young said,
well,
the shadow human shadow extends all the way down to hell.
Okay,
we're going to try that one more time because I failed there.
Uh,
let's try this again.
I touch with the depths of your anger.
You know,
lots of people are resentful about all sorts of things.
They're resentful about,
oh,
women.
And they're resentful about men and their research and they're resentful of the
left.
Wait 26,
present politicians and resentful about the,
like the cataclysmic force of nature and its ability to make people sick and
suffer and they're resentful about their own.
And now he's in the boat.
They're bad parents suffer both nature and stuff.
And it's true.
A lot of people
say that say the systems that we live in are what causes our suffering,
and that's true.
It can add to the suffering,
but ultimately the suffering is just being itself,
you know,
and.
Yeah.
Uh,
yeah.
And you know,
the,
the very idea of resentment.
I've just come across a paper or a book called on resentment.
I'm forgetting who the authors are and it's a
constantly.
It goes over different people including a nature and Virginia Woolf on and finch
who was a 17th century poet,
I think,
you know,
she was a very much against the Patriarchy and Virginia Woolf basically spells
out that it was a and finches,
you know,
dwelling in her own writing that contributed to her a resentment and that the
very act of writing for her was,
you know,
the,
uh,
the source of her own mental illness.
And it's constantly,
it,
you constantly see that these authors or writers mentioned resentment as a
mental illness.
And I never,
I mean,
I've heard Peterson talk about it and he may have even explicitly said that,
but,
you know,
never have.
I,
uh,
you know,
never outside of him have I thought about it like that or heard it from somebody
else.
Yeah,
it's interesting.
Okay.
I've listened to a lot of his Bible lectures and when the store is the way he
describes the enable story,
it really made me think about like in my own life when I've thought about house,
maybe I blame someone else for my problems or how I blamed,
like,
you know,
the fact of being then I thought about and that makes sense because like,
what am I actually blaming,
not blaming the fact that I'm just alive and if I'm blaming that,
then uh,
maybe I should do something to make that better rather than just blaming
everyone else.
Um,
yeah,
it certainly has.
I think it happens to everybody.
Yeah.
Uh,
you know,
if,
I,
I guess everybody can be a victim,
but I think what's another interesting thing in that book it,
I forget the author who,
I think it might've been a character guard that said,
I'm not sure that might be another person that,
you know,
you need a victim,
you need a victimizer,
but then you also need this,
you know,
this third person,
this spectator who basically is emancipated from the resentment or resentment or
sorry,
emancipated from the victimization,
who is able to see it and you know,
almost empathize with the people who are being victimized.
And Peterson talks about that too,
not necessarily in this video,
but he talks about how,
you know,
it's,
it can be evil to,
um,
to empathize with somebody else's problems
and
you're robbing them of their own capacity to solve them.
Right?
They like taking on their problems,
stealing.
Then yeah,
I listened to a,
uh,
Steven Hicks called a post explaining postmodernism and kierkegaard comes up
quite a bit,
but,
uh,
anyway,
so I guess maybe we should get back to the video and see what comes up next.
All right.
So I'm at 39 seconds.
Okay,
let me,
I'm at 49 and I'll come back to the.
I'll come back to 39.
Okay.
Likelihood you have of terrible capacity for destructive testing in the boat.
They're bad.
God like the list is just bloody endless.
And that can make you very,
very angry that that's part of that resentment at 54 dark.
And one thing you mentioned is a two says the list is almost endless and that's
sort of goes along the lines of it reaches to the deepest depths of hell if you
really follow that,
uh,
that list,
right?
Yeah.
Uh,
you know,
you can always think of a worse place you could be in.
You could always think of a worse thing that you could do.
I mean,
yeah,
it's absolutely endless.
I mean,
you,
you hear about,
you know,
atrocities in the world and though some stand out more than others.
Um,
and you know,
dare I say know genocide of
6 million plus you had the concentration camps.
Then you also had the in the,
uh,
oh yeah.
Your blood left in eastern Europe as they move towards
Russia.
Um,
but you know,
it
can always be worse.
I mean,
here's a visual for you.
So there's a train that night train that goes from Moscow to St Petersburg and
uh,
I took that terrain and the entire,
almost the entire length of the railway is just grades
and it's quite the distance.
It takes a eight to nine hours or so to the trainer there.
So
yeah,
that's it.
You can see them in the moonlight.
You could,
you just like the reflections of the crosses.
It's millions or hundreds.
At least hundreds of thousands.
I could see like the one that train track it was crazy.
Yeah,
like things,
things going to be way more,
way worse than then you could even imagine that.
Yeah.
I can't even comprehend that now.
I mean,
seeing that would just probably leave me numb for a little while.
You know,
it was hard to really contemplate when I was only 17,
but I still kind of remember it.
Um,
the,
it was not,
never seen anything like that before.
It reminded me of my grandparents when they went to a,
their insurance stationed in Germany after the war and uh,
they would go to the Canadian,
an ally,
a grave sites and it just the miles and miles of a cross as well and looked
some,
I guess Jewish graves in some Muslim grades,
but mostly mostly,
uh,
crosses.
But I remember my grandma,
my mom remembers my grandma just crying and crying and crying.
Yeah.
Because these are all men that she might've known,
right?
Yeah.
No.
Oh.
Anyways,
so we're,
I'm at 54 seconds.
I'll,
uh,
I'll start.
You can go ahead,
start.
Maybe we'll stop at like why you choose the next stop.
Alright.
Just tell me a desire to bring things down.
Wished that everyone else suffered and desire to shake your fist at God and all
of that really dark.
You know,
Young said,
well the shadow human shout,
it extends all the way down to help and he really meant that,
you know,
because all the terrible things that people are motivated to do are associated
with that shadow domain.
And like none of you are any.
None of you are saints in any likelihood.
You have a terrible capacity for destructiveness and when you start to consult
your resentment and to see how angry you are,
it can terrify you or deceive the depths of that anger sometimes will manifest
itself in very good.
Alright,
so I stopped at.
Yeah,
I wonder sometimes what it would be like
four,
some of the,
uh,
people who
err on the side of social justice to actually see what,
what the possibilities of their own thinking,
what the fruit of their
theories.
But if you were to play out their own
narrative,
yeah,
if you were to play out their own narrative,
what that would lead to and you know,
it's probably inevitably leads to the same,
you know,
if it's,
if it's fueled by resentment,
probably if it fuels and is always fed with the same resentment,
then it will inevitably lead to murder.
I mean that's,
well most utopic vision.
The problem with them is that they can never really be achieved.
I guess good to have some goals,
like reduce suffering.
That's not a bad goal,
but if your idea's elimination of suffering at all.
Oh,
oh,
more suffering than it's ever been seen.
And history,
at least in the 20th century,
uh,
has shown us showing us that that's,
that's,
that's history that we know this history in the past that's just as bad.
It's all for offer utopia.
Yeah.
You can never really achieve it.
Right.
Okay.
Yeah,
you can't,
you can't eliminate suffering.
But,
uh,
another interesting,
another interesting
idea in that book on resentment,
I'll throw it into the description though,
you know,
it's an 50 to $80 ebook
is,
and I forget who says this.
It's,
you know,
it's a thinker that most other people would know,
but they mentioned that it's a,
that it's in an impotent lust for revenge.
You know,
it's almost like the person knows that they're vulnerable.
Victim knows that they're vulnerable,
but that they can't do anything.
And so their resentment is fueled by their own impotency.
I mean,
it's almost like this,
uh,
the more whether or not they're,
they feel sorry whether or not a person is wronged.
Like if a person continues to,
to,
uh,
to think
about being victimized,
then you know,
they,
they just keep fueling the resentment and it's an,
it's easy.
It's,
you know,
it can easily happen,
especially if you start to,
you know,
like Peterson says you,
I don't know if he says this,
but you know,
if you keep feeding the dragon,
you know,
it just keeps getting bigger and bigger and just ignore it too.
Yeah.
And if you ignore it,
but,
you know,
even if you,
if you can stop for a little while and then continue again later,
you know,
it's,
it made the dragon may have gotten smaller but you know,
it's still a drag and then it hasn't completely disappeared yet.
Anything you ignore a will get bigger in the background and we'll start taking
up more and more of your,
uh,
your thoughts because you're not dealing with the problem.
Yeah.
But also,
but also if you feed it,
that's also gonna cause problems as well because you know,
if you're adding to it,
you're adding to the problem rather than confronting.
It was really a,
when you confront resentment,
you're really just confronting yourself and a lot of people don't have the
courage to do that and fair enough,
this,
that's a tough one to do,
but if you want to get better,
you've got to do it.
Yeah.
Because,
you know,
your resentment is,
is personal.
It's all the ways in which,
unless it's,
you know,
in fueled by ideology.
And then it may be that,
you know,
the idea that there is an idea that's controlling you rather than you.
I'm expounding an idea,
but let's say that the resentment is personal and there's not an idealogue
driving it.
Um,
then you really have to,
you know,
get a,
hold on it,
get a hold of it and figure out what exactly.
Well,
yeah,
it seems like Peterson says like the socialists and if he got that from Orwell,
uh,
the Socialists don't love the poor,
they just hate the rich.
And the strange thing with that is that they actually,
they hate the rich,
but the ideal idealize Islam,
and that's why they hate them because they're resentful of the fact that they're
not rich or you know,
there's some sort of moral quandary with having wealth,
which really there isn't.
The problem is they don't have it.
So they wanted to destroy it and that's like the,
you know,
the typical out difficult.
But the Cain and Abel story is all,
is that,
that's what that can enable story is it's someone who idealized is something and
then tries to destroy it in order to make themselves better.
But what happens when you destroy it,
you realize that you've just destroyed your ideal,
which in a sense you've destroyed yourself.
Where your soul is.
The Christians would say,
yeah,
let's just,
you know,
I'm going to continue on.
Yeah,
I'm at the [inaudible] 37.
me too.
Okay.
Fit.
Just fantasies.
You know,
which you might not want to become conscious of because they're so brutal,
let's say.
And so aggressive that you can't even believe that you generate them the nice
person.
That's you.
It's like,
so it's quite frightening to open that door and see all that and that also
associates you with the entire dark shadow of mankind,
right?
The tannic element of the human character and,
but it opens the door to understanding as well to,
to understanding how people can do terrible things because you could see
yourself as one of the people who could be positive things.
That's through twelfth.
So when he says people like they're on aisle,
I've found a lot of people are like,
if you ask them a question that if they're capable of doing a terrible thing,
they'll usually say no,
right?
Because there's not a monster,
but that's the problem.
Because if they're a human being and other human beings are capable of doing
that terrible thing,
then automatically you're capable of doing that terrible thing too,
right?
The only thing that's stopping you is something,
So is it because you're a coward?
Which is what Nietzsche would say,
um,
or is it because the laws or is it because you have a reason not to do it?
And if you asked where the resentment thing comes in,
because maybe your reason is that you,
okay,
you have resentment,
figured you're dealing with it yourself,
like it's your problem and you're not externalizing it to those things.
And
Yeah,
I,
uh,
I read,
I haven't read police battalion are.
I haven't read ordinary men completely.
In fact,
they haven't even started reading it yet because I was,
I was seeing little excerpts and one of the excerpts that stood out to me was
that a police battalion,
I think it was one on one,
was made up of,
I forget who the author.
I'm a classified three different types of men.
The men who were eager to kill the men who were,
I'm
a
who would,
who would kill but weren't initiating the action.
They would have to be initiated against.
They would have to have someone initiate them to kill,
but they would kill willingly.
Then the men who would basically try and avoid the killing.
And you know,
obviously,
you know,
all three groups said we're,
well,
we're part of the problem.
Not only part of the problem,
but you know,
I guess I'd have to read it to find out maybe more about the groups
for sure.
Like I have a lot more reading to do.
I've been doing more and more reading over time,
but uh,
you know,
there's a lot of stuff to read.
So yeah.
I'm just wondering.
Yeah,
I'm wondering,
you know,
how much some of these individuals were in touch with their own darkness?
You know,
I,
I would be hard pressed to think that,
you know,
the eager killers were all,
in touch with their own.
Or maybe they would be the ones in touch with their own darkness,
but they were the ones who continued to feed it.
Yeah.
That's the other.
Feeding the dragon rather than integrated into themselves.
Yeah.
If you're,
if you're,
if you're not really using the tool of consciously,
then then you're,
then you're just feeding the dragon.
If you're.
There's times when you should be a monster,
but if it's like shooting women in the back of the head and open and feels like
that's not really a time,
that's obviously,
that's obviously a pathological situation,
but
you've got to control it.
And maybe the men who killed willingly because they knew that they had to,
whatever that means.
Um,
we,
uh,
were ones who were in touch,
but because they wouldn't initiate it themselves,
maybe they were ones who,
God,
it's hard to say because,
you know,
Peter.
Yeah.
They were following [inaudible] Peterson,
you know,
obviously mentioned,
when you start to think for yourself that,
you know,
I could be one of the,
you think to yourself that I can be one of those guards,
w,
what would I have to do to make sure that that would never happen now will,
I don't know because I haven't read the book,
but I don't know of any three of any individual in that group that chose not to.
Or how about this?
Like what would it take?
What would your life have to be like in order to make a decision like that?
Like realistically,
yeah,
that's another question should be asked to because maybe if anybody's capable of
it,
it maybe,
maybe it's good to realize what you would have to,
what kind of situation you would have to be in to a reset.
Same sort of decision.
Yeah.
That's necessary to even begin thinking about it,
you know,
to put yourself in that position,
you have to wonder,
you know,
what,
what situation would I have to be in?
Especially for the people who claim that they could never be in that position
because they're good people.
You know,
they were good people.
We only killed $100,
million innocent civilians in the 20th century for ideals,
but it was worth it.
Right.
It's an absolute monsters.
Oh,
I wouldn't.
If I was in charge of the utopia,
it would have been ushered in.
Okay,
well then what happens to people like you a while you get taken out by the cell
in type system,
what Peterson says anyways.
And that makes sense.
I know.
Yeah.
I'm going to continue to let this go.
I'm at 10 to 12.
Okay.
No,
because then you.
Well then maybe you start to be motivated to be the sort of person who wouldn't
do terrible things.
You know,
if you can really come to terms with the fact that that's part and parcel of
you.
It also is some perverse sense.
It's also a discovery of your own strength though,
because you know if you have that desire for aggression,
that desire for destruction and that that ability to fantasize in that
aggressive manner,
it also means that you can incorporate some of that into your speech and into
your actions so that you're a lot more immovable,
right,
and and a lot more of a force to contend with.
It can give you some respect for yourself when you realize that you're a force
of destruction as well as creation,
and then you're also more likely to treat yourself with a bit more intelligent.
Caution,
you know,
to know that you're a part of you is a ticking bomb in some sense that could go
off and so you,
you,
you tried a bit more lightly around yourself and maybe you encourage people to
tread more lightly around you as well.
Okay,
so I know that's too in my life where,
uh,
if I'm,
if I'm passive,
people sort of tread all over you,
but if you take yourself seriously and you don't let yourself get pushed around
and people read off that too,
and then they treat you better,
you know,
they treat you seriously.
Yeah.
But I've also found
that,
uh,
sometimes,
in my own experiences through work,
you know,
a lot of times when I worked in a cabinet shop,
I'd be somewhat aggressive sometimes trying to rally people together and some,
you know,
more often than not that aggression,
it could be a better place.
I'm trying to ask somebody for help,
uh,
and people just thinking,
you know,
well,
we don't have to do that or you know,
that's not required to me or you're not my boss and the,
it would be for the good of the company,
you know.
Well,
that's another thing too,
is like you have to match it with your perceived competence competency to,
um,
if you've earned sort of the,
uh,
if you've earned your stripes so to speak.
I find that people are way more willing to take you seriously.
Like I've,
I've worked in two different trades.
I've been a carpenter and I've been a nominal electric later and uh,
I was a young guy so I had no experience.
I had very little knowledge by just kind of like did all the hard work and
eventually an ass a lot of questions and eventually they're like,
okay.
They started taking it more seriously and I got my apprenticeship and stuff.
And then I met six months later I moved to a different trade altogether,
but I just kept trying to move up.
But my point is,
is that by getting up,
I actually jumped ahead of other guys that were,
uh,
also apprentices,
but there were there longer because my work ethic pushed me into a more
respectable position.
So when I would mention something they would take it seriously,
which was also helpful.
But I haven't been in the other position to where I'm trying to bring up ideas
and I have an earned my stripes yet I'm kind of too incompetent to like make a
change and then people just ignore you or whatever.
Yeah.
I find it much more tough when you're a,
you know,
you work longer and your competency level is already fairly high.
But know people aren't necessarily.
Well you might have a high.
But I'm not that I'm talking to myself up,
but,
you know,
I guess there's always different situations.
Um,
but we'll have,
you know,
what exactly do you think Peterson means by integrating,
integrating it,
your speech by what you're saying by basically taking yourself seriously and not
being passive.
Like what would be an example you think of?
Like for example,
when I was working in carpentry,
did we ever doing a garage for a,
a big,
a large residential building?
And uh,
I noticed that my cousin was actually contracted us the person to do the roofing
and stealing and stuff of all the concrete.
And I noticed that one of the walls on the parking garage wasn't sealed with
tar.
And I've mentioned that to my,
I was an apprentice,
so I mentioned to my carpenter a journeyman and he's like,
oh yeah,
that makes sense.
Normally as he called me.
And so I went and got tempted to talk to her.
He went and went and talked to the superintendent and the Superintendent said,
ah,
now we don't need to worry about it.
So then they fill it in,
right?
Because they're almost like the space.
And I fill that in with backfill and down over the weekend it and all the water.
Although water from the rain soaked through the concrete and was like,
that's a huge problem,
right?
Yeah.
So they had to take it all out and then we seal the whole thing,
which would have been solved already if they listened to me,
but they didn't listen to me because I was just a dumb apprentice by this.
Noted that there was a problem and I had,
I thought of a solution.
So I presented it and my journeymen thought it was a good idea.
So he passed it on and then they didn't take it seriously,
but then they had to fix it anyways.
So it cost them lots of money.
Maybe that.
Yeah.
But because I did something like that,
they,
they'd take me.
It started taking more seriously.
Um,
fair enough.
Right.
You don't want like there's a bunch of young idiots out there that think they
know everything,
which is like the first day when you think the.
So they say the Delphi of the Oracle of Delphi said that socrates was the wisest
of the Greeks because he alone movie knew nothing.
And uh,
this true,
the more you know,
you don't know.
So this sort of a good thing to keep in mind.
You gotta know if you're competent before you try to make change,
which a lot of people are like,
Eh,
I don't need to do that.
So they just go out and run around like a bull in a China shop and no one takes
them seriously because why would you?
Right.
Yeah.
That makes a lot of sense.
I think that's what Peterson means with a.
When he says like,
make you clean your room,
it's a prove to yourself that you have competency to do so because if you can't
do that,
then maybe you should reassess your own competency and it's people make fun of
it because it's like silly,
right?
But the point is is you're supposed to test your competency competency or making
a room and then you test your competency and other things.
Maybe keeping your house clean and uh,
and then try to realize that if you know that you're competent,
then you have the confidence in your speech and the precision of your speech to
make a bigger suggestions more,
more,
more worldly inside your family or inside your friend circle or your work
outside of your own personal life.
Maybe then you could have some confidence in your competency because otherwise,
what are you,
right?
You're just,
you could just be any random joe with that ideas.
And are they supposed to take everyone seriously?
It was too many people know to do that.
Yeah.
So that's why you're saying it's important to prove to yourself that you have
competency.
That's what the whole cleaning room thing is
least in my opinion.
Yeah.
He tied it together nicely.
All right.
Well,
do you want to keep going?
We got it.
Yeah.
Okay.
I got a three.
18 almost started up.
Okay,
well did.
I really admired that.
I know have a clearly dangerous side and you don't want to get,
you don't want to have that activated any more than necessary,
but it's also what makes them respectable and strong,
especially if they have that under control.
So.
Oh,
that's a bit of a dialogue about shadow integration.
It's a very
challenging undertaking,
you know,
to pull in that dark side of your character and that would be all the things
that you've repressed or failed to develop as a consequence of trying to be a
harmless and uh,
well let's say harmless,
harmless citizen who looks virtuous on the surface.
That's the union persona.
And you need that because everybody needs a mask that they wear in public,
like a suit,
you know,
so that we can tolerate seeing each other on the street.
We don't have to look right into our depths every time we interact you need that
persona,
but now it has to be transcendent.
And the way to transcend that is to integrate.
The darker parts of the character are very useful demand.
For example,
I've noticed that if you see like sjws how they dress,
they always stressed with like,
you know,
kind of unconventionally a lot of the time.
Not all of them do,
but sort of the crazy ones do I haven't seen,
you know,
other than some of the protests that Peterson has been at.
Yeah,
I know.
I kind of know what you're talking about.
Yeah.
Yes.
So that,
that's sort of like the reason why they do that is because they're trying to be
unconventional,
but the result and uh,
the results and feelings from a,
I guess people that are conventional as they see sort of see sort of the chaos
in their own minds being expressed.
Right?
So they show themselves as incompetent and then they show themselves further and
competent in the way they speak.
So when they cry and like that,
there's like those memes of people crying when trump was elected or sworn in or
whatever.
Um,
and it just,
like these people are showing,
their masks are falling off essentially,
and it's important to have those masks,
like when,
if you're coming,
if you come across someone that's like dressed shabbily and they smell and uh,
they're not,
they're sort of,
I guess you could say unconventional,
but really they just have poor hygiene.
Your art kind of put off,
right?
You don't watch it.
They might interact with light,
but you're going to try to avoid them.
Right.
And uh,
yeah.
So yeah,
I,
I wonder,
um,
yeah,
I think I'll start looking for that more.
I definitely can say I have seen that in some of the people that stick out in my
head and some of the videos,
yeah,
like if you've come across sort of like a homeless guy and if you stare at him,
like he might start freaking out at you,
right?
Because you're,
you're seeing him for what as he is and he's probably a little bit embarrassed
by that.
So he might come at you or he might yell at you or he show his chaos and which
stocks because you don't want to treat people like that,
but that's just the way things are sometimes.
So,
uh,
it's important if you want to see another important side of this competency
thing is you got to appear competent because people might not know and if you
show that you can appear competent,
then people are more likely to want to interact with you because they're going
to see you.
Uh,
that's a more peaceful person I guess in some way because they're going to be
able to know that,
okay,
well,
if a person's able to take care of themselves hygienically,
then you know,
maybe I can have an actual conversation with this person compared to a guy going
to be covered in actual garbage.
Then this can be difficult,
right?
Because you're going to be constantly smelling or,
or whatever.
Yeah.
I
don't know how much it's hearsay or where it came from,
but I heard that Marx was a.
was it pretty dirty,
dirty person?
Smelled,
or we call them,
we call them,
I call them dirty Santa Claus.
Man filled with resentment is so,
so resentful that he almost started his own children who really.
Yeah.
Well it doesn't even have a job.
So he wasn't really keeping up with the Miller,
isn't he really is the only,
only reason he was able to like get by lists because angles,
who was a son of a rich industrialists was sending him money basically
and uh,
to help him with his writings.
I suppose that's,
that's the only reason why otherwise I think he had like four or five kids.
Don't quote me on that,
but yeah.
Yeah.
Didn't you horror on his own wife to A.
I don't know.
I can't say if that's true or not.
But yeah,
I mean,
well,
okay.
Don't want to pick on somebody that can't defend themselves anymore.
I want to start again at 4:32.
Only a little bit left.
So.
Okay,
I'll start up.
That's very difficult to socialize that competitiveness,
but unbelievably useful in terms of force and the character if you could manage
it.
Yeah.
I think a sane socialized,
socializing the competitiveness,
that's has a lot to do with what you were talking about with competency and
um,
no,
if you are competitive,
you know,
a great thing to do is first to appear competent so that you can
display your competitiveness with some.
Perfect.
I don't know what I'm saying.
Well,
when I was,
when I was younger,
I used to think I was really,
really competent.
Like I,
I thought I knew everything right.
Which you don't really understand like when you're 18 and you think you know
everything,
you don't realize how little you actually know.
Right.
So what I was,
what I would I changed over time was I just started reading more and then I
started realizing I'm like,
Oh shit,
I almost,
I know almost nothing about the more I've read,
um,
the more I realized that,
but there's like 17,
18,
19 year old kid,
sometimes 20 year olds that are out there protesting and they don't really know
what the hell they're protesting.
Like you can even see it in even Peterson and his history.
He's been in this situation where he was,
he ran for healing,
he was like 16 or something.
I ran for the vice president of the,
a new Democratic Party in Alberta,
which is the Socialist Party,
sort of democratic socialist party in Canada.
And I was also a member of that party and I used to like do campaigning for a
couple of the people that are eventually won seats and I was like a campaign
called captain or whatever have a section of the,
of the city.
And uh,
I mean it was fine.
It was interesting experience,
but now I look back on it.
There was a lot of Weirdos in that,
in that grouping.
Like there's a lot of people that they weren't very competent,
but they thought they knew everything.
Yeah.
You know,
and that's the dangerous combination.
I'm actually remembering a couple of times in my own hometown where I had seen
a,
a random group that had popped up,
but Lyndon Larouche group,
which was like a halfway between a conspiracy theory group.
And
I don't know,
I don't know exactly how to more like a cult.
A cult would be a good,
a good way to define them,
but I remember a lot of the people and I know I'm harping on it again,
but we're dressed up and dressed really odd.
Yeah.
And a lot of them were,
you know,
as old as me and it was just a,
I had approached the table because they were just at the local post office and I
was there for something and I'm thinking to myself like,
these guys are a little bit weird.
So I grabbed the brochure and started looking at it and you know,
so you know,
some of the literature sound good?
Yeah.
It seems interesting on the surface,
but you know,
just judging by the people who are already there,
it's like I don't think I want to get involved with these people.
It's kind of funny how that's kind of habits unconscious.
Something you picked up unconsciously.
It might.
Yeah,
it,
it's,
it's funny because it stares you right in the face,
but it's still sort of unconscious because you give them this era of respect
that they may not deserve a automatically because you know,
that's a way to have a peaceful society,
but unconsciously maybe subconsciously or unconsciously you,
you see the,
you know,
something's up with them.
Yeah.
Subconsciously I think it was the word I was looking for.
I'm not sure what the proper terminology is.
That as again,
I'm not educated.
I just read a lot.
Um,
but yeah,
it's interesting you see it with a scientology people too sometimes,
like,
still crazy.
Yeah.
I've never,
I've never come across anybody in scientology.
They have a chapter in Vancouver,
in the poor area,
like we're a lot of the homeless people live now and I don't know exactly how
they,
maybe they survived because almost pick of the money,
which I think could be kind of a bad marketing plan.
Um,
but uh,
yeah,
they're right in the middle of the downtown east side,
like right beside the unit.
Do you ever heard of Mark Emery?
The principal?
No.
Okay.
Well,
he has a store downtown or he did back in the day called cannabis culture or
something and it was like right beside the scientology office,
which I thought was funny because Mark Emery,
he's the kind of guy that would get,
you would expect him to make sort of like a pot centric,
a religion.
Uh,
ironically,
but,
uh,
he wouldn't have that.
He would never join scientology,
but I wonder if maybe I'm scientology put themselves there on purpose or,
or maybe it was just you happened to be there.
Well,
they do a,
they do kind of prey on the abused.
The addicted.
Yeah.
The vulnerable people vulnerable.
That's a better way to.
Yeah,
that's a better word I'm looking for and you know,
that,
you know,
it's scary because in 2005 or six,
they were actually one of the will self.
They claimed it themselves,
but they were one of the fastest growing religions in the world.
Uh,
I think they were publishing and oh man,
I don't know how many different languages,
which is scary.
Yeah.
Well,
like,
who?
The Mormons are passing them.
Not that I'm really a fan of more medicine,
but it's definitely better than.
Yeah,
yeah.
At least.
Or an old drug addicted.
They dress well and don't smell.
So that's what wasn't good for wives,
you know,
I'm just,
there's nothing wrong with that.
I would not lie for us.
Way Too much.
One's enough.
Exactly.
But uh,
yeah.
Well,
so what do you,
what do you think seems pretty.
Well,
I think,
uh,
yeah.
Maybe we will just cut it here and we'll come back later and above.
All right.
Take care of
it.
Do.